[Music]
if you or someone you know is
experiencing rotator cuff pain
intermountain healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment are here to help
through exercises and sports medicine
here's how
my name is dr brian davis and we are
here at intermountain healthcare we are
in the sunset our beautiful office over
here at southern hills hospital
i am a physical medicine and
rehabilitation specialist my job is to
work with folks for non-surgical needs
of
their joint issues and so as we get
older the likelihood of us developing
rotator cuff issues goes up dramatically
when we're younger a rotator cuff
functions better unfortunately over time
as we continue to use our shoulders in
ways that are different than our
four-legged cousins we end up putting
greater demands on those rotator cuffs
over time what happens is that the cuff
begins to fail there is less flexibility
within the tendon the tendon has loss of
its normal blood flow which doesn't
allow for proper healing and we end up
going down this cascade of pain and
dysfunction and tendon damage that
unfortunately can lead to the point
where an individual may not be able to
reach overhead rotator cuff disease can
affect younger individuals but in those
circumstances it's usually because of
overuse injuries they might have played
a sport like a racket sport or a
throwing sport and that may have set
them up to have rotator cuff issues and
still again those don't tend to happen
until our 30s and our 40s and beyond but
as we get into our 50s and 60s and
beyond that's where we're much more
likely to develop those rotator cuff
issues that are going to be much more
problematic and plaguing for us
the most important thing from the
perspective of a clinician like myself
is first of all to try to prevent these
from happening in the first place which
means that you have to have the proper
exercise program you have to have the
proper training or trainer to help you
or you have to just be able to
evaluate your own fitness and make
certain that you're doing the right
exercises that are going to help
maintain your posture help maintain your
fitness and your general strength and
flexibility so one of the most important
things that we'll use in our instruction
for our patients is something as simple
as using a rubber band and what's nice
about these you can stick them in
between a door or have somebody hold
them for you and they create the
resistance so that you can work on
muscle strength
another thing that i actually use
throughout the course of this last 12 to
18 months during the pandemic are bands
to work on strength and other fitness
working on your postural muscles you can
use it to stick it over a door you can
stick it under the door next to it and
then you can create that resistance that
you're looking for
and as we move into that older age group
hopefully we age in gracefully but if we
develop a rotator cuff issue that's
where someone like myself would step in
and say all right here's what we need to
do in terms of the exercise protocols
here's how we have to work on your
posture and here's what we're going to
do to try to rehab this so we don't have
to go down that surgical pathway
thank you intermountain health
healthcare for sponsoring this segment
for more information just head to
intermountainhealthcare.org